passion but it's a passionate passion
passion
hello believe nation today we're going
to talk about how you can have passion
and as always guys as you're watching if
you hear something that really inspires
you please leave it down the comments
below put quotes around it as well so
other people can be inspired and when
you write it down it's much more likely
to sink into yourself as well enjoy I
[Music]
think the most beautiful part about life
is finding what you love to do and
finding your place in it and finding a
way to make that a reality whether you
love to paint or to make music or to
play sports or you know write whatever
it is that you love to do in life or
whatever it is that you love to live or
the people you like to be around and
finding ways to make that a reality like
I fell in love with hip-hop when I was
real little and I started writing raps
and making beats and I was like this is
what I love to spend my time doing and I
want to find a way to make that a
reality and get to travel the world and
get to you know live the way I want to
share that with people you went to play
music when you quit school you didn't go
to become an actor well I'd already I
was already placed I started playing the
guitar at the age of 12 I felt a passion
for it that yeah it was the first real
passion that I that I that I had and I
and I can safely say because I feel and
I felt then the word ambition has become
dirty you know yeah because I'm Bishan
somehow implies that the result I know
I know I know cry I'll probably be
crying about Saturday
so ambition was a dirty word to me
because it felt like you were working
for some gang or a material or some
status or so I literally don't remember
going through puberty because I locked
myself in a room at the age of 12 12 13
and I just played the guitar I learned
things off records and taught myself how
to play and it was my life and it was
the only solace it was the only
sanctuary it was the only security it
was the it was my first love
many people are what we call managers or
CEOs and today they can spend seven
years in to watch business and
eventually then they might move and be
see you in a car business or in a
crystal brand you know these people are
clever and great entrepreneurs but they
are not necessarily deeply connected
forever21 passion I am connected just to
watches I don't I would never like to do
another job of course I have other
little passions I love wine I love
cheese
I love classic cars but I would never
transform them in a business because my
passion is not deep enough
while watches is my life if I want if I
have to die I want people to remember
two things I want my children and my
wife to remember my love and I want
people to remember my contribution to
the watch business so that's really my
objective that's why I would never leave
this business and not many I have been
in the business since eight
74 so it's nearly 40 years 39 years in
the same business and I don't know many
people in this business that have been
39 years there some great people came
but they came from our car brand of came
from Ferrari or from Maserati and joined
the watch business and maybe in seven
years they're gonna move and go to
Hermes or rito so it's different I am a
watch fan a watch freak people won't
know what I went through between the
second and third album of the fear that
was implemented in me even though I knew
I was talented I have to be confident in
what I do and that song was one of the
first songs that I recorded for the
album and I was actually going to call
the album masterpiece and I just thought
no it doesn't make sense if people hear
it on its own it just sounds like on
being an absolute [ __ ] but for me I
I've never made it I've never finished
my painting until the day that my eyes
closed and I don't wake up I feel like
I'm still putting towards my masterpiece
and I want to work hard and I'm okay to
say hey I've messed up I do things I say
things I wear things I date people I
shouldn't but I'm human and they're all
building on something that we hope can
even standing of the test of time and I
think that's what that song means to me
and I I really really put it towards the
other people that have gone you can't do
this or lied about me and said I'm
difficult or this and that and call me a
diva and when I'm not I'm passionate no
there's there's a very very when people
can't deal with our passion that you are
they attack you and that's the same
within any any anyone because everybody
kept asking me what does it feel like
what does it feel like when you got the
nomination that little girl from
Washington DC what did it feel like when
you heard your name mine was a
rollercoaster ride I did I was nominated
for this and wasn't for that you know so
I really put it out of my head cuz I
don't really do what I do for the warts
you know like you said if you're
passionate about your work all of the
accolades will come you got to stay
focused on what God puts you on earth to
do
yeah I mean I was very fortunate I
started working I just started trying to
work at 14 and I got on a sitcom when I
was 16 I dealt with a lot of nose mostly
personal nose you know within my family
it's hard for a 14 year old to say I'm
leaving Kentucky I'm moving to New York
but I knew I felt so strongly it's it
feels insane to be a teenager and no I
knew that it was the right thing to do
anyways it was going to work out well no
I wouldn't be supportive of my teenager
as I kinda live in Nara I thought I
would they you know they thought I was
gonna get killed I'm surprised I didn't
get killed but it was like this
fire and also this like I just knew it
so I eventually saved up babysitting
money and went and did it and what about
the the the the business of being what
you are now they had the musician the
songwriter I mean did you did you
display an early talent for singing or
for I didn't actually I got thrown out
of the choir did you I was thrown out of
the choir for I think as far as I know
it was for talking and and I always
remember my dad used to say to me you
know because I used to say dad that when
I was like you know 16 17 18 and my dad
was threatened to throw me out of the
house if I didn't get job within a
certain amount of time so obviously I
went out and got jobs but I was saying I
want to be a singer you know I think I'm
gonna be rich and famous and he would
say you know everybody wants to be a pop
saying everybody was I said and I would
say no dad everybody wants to be a pop
singer when they're 12 you know when
they're 12 I'll this is my whole life
this is what I want to do but um but but
I've lost my train of thought
reason famous your ambition I mean was
that oh I think I had two very very
strong ambitions and they've always
fought against one another always and
one was a passion for music and an
ability to communicate through music and
really a sense of purpose through music
and two was this desire to be an
enriched and famous he's not right
because actually rich never came into it
I actually realized about six months ago
someone put a question to me and
actually realized that at no point
during my early life when I was in all
my ambitions or even when III started to
to realize my ambitions at no point did
I ever occur to me though one of the
byproducts of this would be that I could
buy whatever I wanted or you know live
in a big house have a flashy car all the
things that are very pleasant you know
but it really hadn't occurred to me had
never occurred to me so I didn't want to
be rich I wanted to just wanted to be
filthily famous
[Music]
is it but I mean
[Music]
what did Cronus achieve for you well
that movie changed my life because we
were more than the underdog more than
the dark horse we were a movie that
nobody wanted to produce nobody was
supporting except my producers in Mexico
and we suddenly were selected for can
and and literally we were all of a
sudden one of the most awarded movies in
in Mexican film history I remember the
first time Kronos won the first award
which was a cash award and before that
award we were in debt for half a million
I want we won the award and literally
like like a beauty contest I was crying
crying in the stage holding this giant
chair and I was trembling and I was
really moved because a I was happy the
movie was being recognized and be I was
not going to jail I watched so many
matches in my life unbelievable and
they're really not so there are some
boring games and then I was asleep and
it's so boring I think while they meet
each other and make this 20 40 50 60 70
80 thousand people in a stadium on this
boring game it's not okay so that's what
we what we want to see we want to enjoy
our own game if we lose okay we like to
win but if we lose with our way it's
okay if we lose with the way of somebody
else it's it's you cannot work with this
so that's it it's very emotional very
fast very strong not boring no chess
like this no yes of course tactical yes
but a detective with with big heart and
technical things are so important you
cannot win without technical things but
the the the emotion make the difference
life in our in our game that's important
well I've always played the violin ever
since I was six years old I begged for
lessons and I've always played and
was actually when I was in college that
I kind of just realized one day that I
didn't love it anymore
and I used to love it and I specifically
didn't study music in school because I
didn't ever want to have the love of my
music beat out of me and so it kind of
broke my heart when I was like I don't
even enjoy this anymore and so I started
thinking okay what can I do - like
invigorate my passion like I started
playing with bands I started just
anywhere I could go to kind of try out
new styles of music and I've always
loved electronic music and it just hit
me one day I need to play and the right
the kind of music that I am loving right
now and so I did and it just brought it
back to life for me it made it so
creative that I became a creator not
just a musician and that's I think what
just invigorated my passion so thank you
guys so much for watching I'd love to
know what did you think of this video
what clip resonated the most with you
that you're going to take and
immediately apply to your life for your
business somehow leave it down in the
comments below and I'm gonna join in the
discussion I'll sort of give a quick
shout out to Kareem Alka Sam thank you
so much Kareem for picking up a copy of
my book your one word it really really
really really means a lot to me and I
hope you're enjoying it so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon